[Music]  I might be business just mind your  business right well except that your  husband's sexual activity is your  business if you didn't intend to share  in that business with him to in effect  make it your business exclusively like  exclusively your business exclusively  the why did you marry him and what sense  is this even a marriage for what reason  is it a marriage why would anybody ever  want to get married man why to celebrate  your relationship to solidify your  commitment to declare your love for one  another to the world  yes but then we go down a rabbit hole  that people don't want to go down of  course which is like now we got to come  up with a definition of marriage what is  it exactly and once you start doing that  uh then you're drawing lines and you  might find that we're excluding certain  types of relationships that you would  prefer to include and that's why we  don't Define it at all and now we have  to call this a marriage also